Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Achtung!
Nicht im Tor!
Kein Tor! Oder doch? Jetzt was entscheidet der Linienöchter? Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Das war's für heute. Ja, herzlich Willkommen zum ersten Rasenfunk-Live. Wer hätte das gedacht? Ein Tribünengespräch im Form eines Tresengesprächs. Wir sitzen hier im wunderschönen Stadion an der Schleißheimer Straße und ich möchte mit zwei Gästen über ihren Beruf sprechen.
Und das ist der Beruf des TV-Kommentators und des TV-Experten. Und deswegen müsst ihr jetzt nochmal sehr viel lauter klatschen, als jetzt gerade hier zu beginnen. Nämlich zum einen begrüße ich zu meiner Rechten, zu euren Linken ein unbeschriebenes Blatt bei Twitter. Aber man kennt ihn vielleicht schon von seiner Tätigkeit bei DAZN, der liebe Ed Felgenradler Ralph Gunesch. Ja, ich habe unbeschriebenes Blatt gesagt. Und zu meiner Linken, zu eurer Rechten ebenfalls Kommentator bei DAZN. Er hat schon viele Stunden zusammen mit Ralph kommentiert. Das heißt, er weiß, was es bedeutet, unter extremsten Bedingungen zu arbeiten und deswegen wird er das auch hier locker meistern. Uli Hebel, Servus Uli! Danke! So, ihr wisst ja, wie das alles beginnt, nämlich zu Beginn jeder Folge muss ich all denjenigen danken, die es möglich machen, dass ich uns hier auf Rasenfunk kosten, eine Spezie und zwei Wasser herstellen konnte. Ich danke allen Unterstützern und vielleicht sind da hier auch welche im Raum. Trauen sich nicht dazu zu stehen. Vielen Dank an alle Rasenfunk-Supporter unter rasfunk.de unterstützen. Kann man dafür sorgen, dass ich vielleicht das nächste Mal hier in einem schillernden, silbernen Anzug sitze? Und wer würde das nicht wollen? Jetzt sprechen wir über den Job als TV-Kommentator und als Fußballexperte. Uli, du hast ja mit dem Felgenralle zusammen schon einige Stunden verbracht. Auf wie viele kommst du denn so ungefähr?
Mehr als mit jeder Frau, die ich jemals heiraten werde. Seit dem letzten Juli, seit einem guten Jahr, sind wir jetzt zusammen. Es sind wahnsinnig viele gewesen. Ich kann dir nicht im Ansatz eine Zahl nennen.
Es dürften entspannte 25 bis 30 Spiele sein. Ganz locker. Meinst du es noch mehr? Das haben wir doch im Monat. Und dann haben wir noch einen Quali. Okay, sagen wir mal 40 Spiele. 40 Spiele und das Ganze mal 90 Minuten. Also wir sind bei 60 Stunden.
Das ist viel. Was ist denn der Reiz daran, ein Spiel nicht alleine zu kommentieren, sondern zu zweit? Die Frage muss eigentlich zuerst an Uli gehen, denn das ist ja das, was man häufiger erlebt, auch in Deutschland noch.
Also ich freue mich im Grunde. Ich habe nur zwei Augen. Und vier Augen sind immer besser als zwei Augen. Und zwei Meinungen sind besser als eine Meinung. Und so wie wir hier alle sitzen, hat jeder immer eine ganz andere Meinung zum Fußballspiel. Und ich bin wahnsinnig froh, dass ich jemanden neben mir habe, in dem Fall dann, der das Ganze beruflich gemacht hat. Ich kann gar nicht mehr Einblick bekommen als von ihm. Es gibt Sachen, die mich selber wahnsinnig interessieren. Ich bin immer noch ein kleines Kind, wenn es ums Fußballspielen geht. Ja, das ist tatsächlich Expertise und die mache ich mir voll zu Nutze.
Ist dann für dich auch Entspannte zu zweit?
Das liegt am Experten. Es gibt Experten, die mich dann ein bisschen mehr fordern, weil ich die einfach reinholen muss und ein bisschen anhauchen, damit sie auftauen. Aber im Grunde ist es entspannter. Wenn mir mal was durchläuft und das passiert oft genug, dann habe ich einfach einen zweiten neben mir.
Was glaubst du denn, Ralph? Kannst du so eine Übertragung geben, was man nicht hat, wenn nur ein Kommentator dabei ist?
Die Frage ist – ich habe genug Zeit zum Antworten, weil die Frage ist tatsächlich etwas schwieriger, etwas komplexer zu beantworten. Na, kleine Rückkopplung. Ich habe quasi im Prinzip an mich selbst den Anspruch, dass der Zuschauer nach dem Spiel auch ein bisschen was dazugelernt hat. Dass er nicht nur jetzt ein Spiel gesehen hat und vielleicht drei Tore, sondern er auch erkennt, warum es jetzt bei der einen Mannschaft funktioniert hat, warum die eine Mannschaft irgendwann mal so den Turn im Spiel gekriegt hat, in welche Richtung auch immer. Und da kann ich sehr, sehr viel aus Erfahrung sprechen, weil ich stand 15 Jahre lang halt auf Profiniveau auf dem Platz und habe das alles mitgemacht. Und während Uli sehr oft das begleitet, was am Ball passiert, schaue ich mir sehr oft an, was passiert außerhalb des Balles. Wie bewegen sich die Leute? Wo sind – ganz banal, das geht jetzt ins Detail – aber wo sind die Räume offen? Wo sind taktische Feinheiten oder auch taktische Fehler? Und da dann die Zusammenhänge aufzuzeigen, die vielleicht der Kommentator nicht sofort erkennt, weil er sehr auf den Ball fokussiert ist, und die vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt jeder Zuschauer sofort erkennt, weil er einfach nicht darauf achtet oder das Spiel nur so halb begleitet oder vielleicht noch nicht dieses taktische, tiefgründige Wissen einfach hat.
Dabei zehrst du ja viel aus den Erfahrungen deiner Profikarriere. Musst du da noch Hintergrundrecherchen, Gespräche führen, um am Ball zu bleiben? Oder hast du Angst, anders gefragt, dass du in 15 Jahren einer von denjenigen bist, der immer alles aus seiner Zeit heraus noch erklärt?
Ich habe mir ganz früh vorgenommen, nicht Sätze anzufangen mit wir früher. Bei uns war das so und so. Das mag ich auch nicht, wenn Opa vom Krieger zählt, und früher war ja alles besser, und früher wurden die Spiele alle gewonnen. Also wenn du die Fußballer fragst, wie es früher war, dann eigentlich waren alle deutsche Meister und haben alle die Champions League gewonnen. Weil die Spiele waren, wurden alle gewonnen. Nein, wir haben genauso viel Scheiße gespielt. Du musst am Ball bleiben, du musst halt schauen, was passiert, wo gibt es Transfers. Das ist jetzt gerade am Anfang der Saison extrem schwierig, weil, wenn du nur siehst, was in der Premier League, was da für ein Roulette unterwegs ist. Und jetzt habe ich heute Nacht Manchester City gegen Manchester United kommentiert und weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob beim nächsten Spiel Lechean noch bei United im Tor steht, weil er unbedingt zur Real Madrid möchte. Da musst du halt am Ball bleiben, aber sind wir mal ehrlich, ich meine, du stellst dir eine vernünftige Twitter-Timeline zusammen, bekommst entsprechend auch viele Artikel in die Timeline gespült. Und wenn es gerade bei England ist, wenn nichts mehr hilft, frage ich Uli, weil gefühlt weiß er in England oder aus England alles.
Also das hoffe ich zumindest.
Du hattest ja auch den Podcast Click and Rush, von dem werden dich hoffentlich einige Hörerinnen und Hörer noch kennen. Sind es auch so die wesentlichen Informationsquellen, die du nutzt oder was? Wie bereitest du dich auf ein Spiel vor?
Ach, das ist tatsächlich Querbeet. Also logischerweise, wie Ralph auch schon gesagt hat, ich nutze tatsächlich auch soziale Netzwerke, die mir einfach meine Quellen rein spülen. Ich nutze selbstverständlich sämtliche Online-Quellen, die es gibt. Das ist in England etwas leichter, in der Ukraine oder Japan etwas schwerer, aber auch da muss ich durch. Und was Journalisten heutzutage viel zu wenig tun, telefonieren. Ich telefoniere wahnsinnig oft mit Leuten, also wer irgendwie Experte für irgendetwas ist, her damit, nehme ich immer. Das ist tatsächlich so. Es geht oft darum, dass ich nur Thesen habe, wenn ich mir ein Spiel, beispielsweise ich mache eine Mannschaft erst zum zweiten, dritten Mal in der Saison, dann gucke ich mir nochmal ein Spiel an. Und dann schreibe ich mir ein paar Thesen raus, was ich so beobachtet habe und frage dann aber jemanden, der die einfach schon länger begleitet. Das macht durchaus Sinn. Selbstverständlich auch andere Journalisten, Kollegen, einfach Fans, ob ich einen richtigen Blick dafür habe. Und im Grunde genommen gibt es keine Quelle, die es nicht gibt, wenn es die gibt.
Du machst ja das, was für viele so ein Traum ist.
Du beschäftigst dich beruflich mit Fußball.
Es gibt ja auch andere, die an diesem Traum arbeiten. Rasenfunk.de unterstützen, sage ich nur. Willst du uns mal sagen, wie bist du in den Job reingekommen?
Also ich versuche es mal ein bisschen kürzer zu machen. Das ist tatsächlich eine etwas längere Geschichte, wie bei den meisten, die irgendwie in den Beruf gekommen sind. Ich habe etwas ganz Untypisches begonnen. Ich habe im Einzelhandel begonnen, im Sport auch, mehr dann im Fußball. Und mein Bruder, dem ich wahnsinnig viel zu verdanken habe in der Richtung, der ist irgendwann einfach mal nach München gezogen. Ich komme gebürtig aus Bukhausen, die sind ja heute auch in der Stadt. Bin dann einfach mit ihm mit und habe dann aber sofort gesagt, als ich das Studium begonnen habe, so ich möchte Kommentator werden. Die lachen dich natürlich erstmal alle aus, weil das wollen sie irgendwie erstmal alle. Und ich habe dann aber versucht, irgendwie relativ schnell das Ganze dann so auf ein anderes Level zu bringen und habe mir dann einfach so einen Plan erstellt, der da hieß, im zweiten Semester Studium musst du im Radio sein, im vierten Semester musst du im Fernsehen sein. Vorher habe ich schon alles print weggearbeitet. Und dann ging es irgendwann mal weiter bei Sky und dann, wie es halt immer so ist, brauchst du jemanden, der dir vertraut, der an dich glaubt. Und da habe ich zwei, drei Menschen gefunden und dann ging alles sehr schnell.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, wo es hier ganz leise werden wird, im Stadion an der Schleißheimer. Denn jetzt reden wir über eine echte Legende. Dein Mentor ist nicht etwa Ralph Gunesch, wahrscheinlich nur menschlichen Dingen, sondern Fritz von Turno Taxis.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Wie gerät man in den Dunstkreis von Fritz von Turno Taxis und wie früh fühlt man sich gesalbt?
Ich fühle mich immer noch gesalbt. Ich sage etwas, was wahnsinnig viel über den Menschen Fritz von Turno Taxis sagt. Ich war damals im Praktikum bei Sky, habe mir erkämpft, dass ich zwei Wochen in den Livesport durfte. Und dann steht da plötzlich so das Who is Who der deutschen Kommentatorenriege – Schrägstrich der Journalisten – Wolf Fuss, Kai Dittmann. Also Riesenvorbilder meinerseits auch. Und dann steht da Fritz von Turno Taxis, wie immer, sehr gut gewandet. Und dann sagt Fritz von Turno Taxis tatsächlich plötzlich zu mir, hallo du bist der Uli. Und dann war ich schon wie ich, wenn ich mit 14, 15 verliebt war. Ich wusste nicht mehr recht, was ich sagen sollte. Ja, also er hat dann gesagt, ich bin der Fritz, danke. Ich habe das vernommen in meiner Zeit. Und habe dann wirklich, da hört man plötzlich sehr, sehr schüchtern, wenn jemand vor dir steht, der 40 Jahre lang diese Szene bestimmt hat und Menschen rausgebracht hat, die wir alle täglich hören und von denen wir gar nicht wissen. Und habe dann aber wirklich mutigerweise ihn gefragt, ob ich ihm denn bitte mal was zeigen dürfte. Und er hat mir dann gesagt, er kommt, das war glaube ich an einem Montag in der Früh, er kommt Donnerstagabend nach der Arbeit zu mir. Zu dem Zeitpunkt war die Relation völlig leergefegt. Donnerstagabend, 19 Uhr. Ich saß alleine am PC, habe irgendwelche beknackten Filme gebrannt für weiß ich wen. Und dann taucht tatsächlich Fritz von Turno Taxis auf.
Und es wurde hell im Raum, obwohl keine Lampe an war.
Und ich wurde dann etwas dunkler, vor allen Dingen rot. Weil ich wusste, in dem Moment entscheidet sich vieles bei mir. Und so lief das im Großen und Ganzen.
Ja, aber was habt ihr denn dann gemacht? Also die Aura Fritz von Turno Taxis, das kann jeder hier erspüren. Allein, wie sie jetzt alle gebannt an unseren Lippen hängen, das ist ja durchaus faszinierend. Aber wo hat er dir denn geholfen? Wie kann ich mir das vorstellen? Sagt er dann hier noch ein Huiuiui und da ein Donnerwetter?
Das habe ich leider nicht. Er wünscht sich das nach wie vor von mir, dass ich das mehr tue. Also jetzt nicht speziell Huiuiui, aber etwas mehr Emotion wünscht er sich von mir. Ne, du kannst dir das tatsächlich vorstellen. Ich habe ihm eine Halbzeit hingelegt. Das war so sein Vergleichsstück, ob ich überhaupt lohne, mit mir zu arbeiten. Und er hat in dieser ersten Hälfte immer wieder alle zwei Minuten angehalten und gesagt, da muss was. Warum sprichst du da nicht auf das Bild? Warum beschreibst du hier? Warum sprichst du hier nicht auf die Zeitlupe? Und, und das ist das Wichtigste, was ich von ihm gelernt habe, egal was ich da tue, egal was auf dem Feld passiert, ihr, die Zuschauer, seid das Wichtigste. Für die muss das bekömmlich sein. Wenn ich einen lustigen Spruch auf der Lippe habe, aber er kommt nicht an, habe ich, habe ich nichts gewonnen. Und so ging es tatsächlich dann vier, fünf Mal, so über vier, fünf Stunden, wo er mir dann immer wieder so am Detail, am Wort, an der Länge der Worte, an der Emotion, am Schrei, an der Beschreibung, an wie er auch immer gesagt hat Ja oder Nein.
Das hört sich unheimlich fast schon mathematisch an, finde ich, dafür, dass es um so einen emotionalen, ja auch kreativen Beruf geht. Wie viel Emotion und Leidenschaft ist denn dann dabei? Weil ich hätte gesagt, von meinem Gefühl her hat Fritz von Toner Taxis vor allem das eine Label nämlich authentisch. Er ist genauso, wie er auch über Fußball denkt. Und das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, hat sich sehr durchgeplant angehört.
Naja, ich sag mal so, also du brauchst in jedem Beruf, und das ist speziell auch in diesen kreativen Bereichen, Handwerk. Du brauchst Regeln, die du, wenn du sie kennst, brechen kannst. Und darum geht's. Erst einmal musst du mitspielen und dann kannst du verschiedene Dinge nach links oder rechts verschieben. Fritz sagt immer, das ist eine komplizierte Sache. Und nach jedem vierten, fünften Satz, als er dann so sein Monolog gehalten hat, hat er gesagt, du merkst also, es ist kompliziert. Und ich weiß jetzt, es ist kompliziert. Und nichtsdestotrotz brauchst du an verschiedenen Stellen, das ist einfach nur Text-Bildsprache, brauchst du Handwerk. Ansonsten wird der Zuschauer zuhause nicht wissen, warum er gerade irgendwie abschaltet, aber er wird zumindest sagen, irgendwas hat nicht gestimmt.
Was sind denn das für Regeln?
Ganz klassisch, ihr kennt alle die Situation, wann der Kommentator Informationen gibt. Beispielsweise, wenn ein Spieler, die Regie wird ihn dir geben, den Keyplayer in den ersten 15 Minuten von beiden Seiten, meinetwegen, der ist immer 7-8 Sekunden im sogenannten Close-Bild. Du siehst ihn also von 5 Metern vor dir. Und erst dann kommt die Information. Und wenn das Bild weggeht und du dann erst die Information bekommst, dann hat mir Fritz immer eine gewischt.
Also, wir haben gelernt, es gibt viele Regeln beim Kommentatorenjob, die es zu beachten gilt. Wie ist denn das, wenn man TV-Expert ist? Kann man es da ein bisschen lässiger angehen?
Grundsätzlich kannst du es ein bisschen entspannter angehen. Allerdings gibt es auch so zwei, drei Grundregeln für uns, die du einfach beachten solltest. Zum Beispiel, wenn der Ball Richtung 16er fliegt, im 16er ist, Schnauze halten. Weil das ist nicht unser Job. Das ist der Job des Kommentators, in dem Moment aufs Bild einzugehen, in dem Moment diese Szene nicht zwingend zu beschreiben, aber den Zuschauern mitzunehmen, dass hier gleich was passiert im 16er. Und wenn die Zeitlupe kommt, dann ist quasi mein Job gefragt, warum ist es zu dieser Situation gekommen? Warum, keine Ahnung, konnten Sie eine Überzahl-Situation auf Außen schaffen? Wo ist der zweite, Sechser, irgendwas in die Richtung? Das muss ich dann schnell erkennen und erklären. Aber das ist eine der ersten Grundregeln, die ich gelernt habe, ist der Ball im 16er Schnauze halten. Und Tore wirken lassen. Also in dem Moment, wo ein Tor fällt, geht es bei mir dann schon los. Und das kriege ich oft vorgeworfen, dass ich dann immer das Negative rausstelle. Natürlich sind das schöne Tore, aber ich bin gelernter Abwehrspieler und suche immer den Fehler beim Tor. Aber lass das Tor erstmal wirken, weil dann kommen ja die jubelnden Spieler im Close und lass die feiern, lass die Emotionen rüberkommen und dann bei der zweiten, dritten Wiederholung einsteigen und analysieren.
Merkst du den Kontrast, Max? Bei ihm wünscht sich der Zuschauer im 16er, dass er sich die Schnauze hält, bei mir über 90 Minuten. Das ist der Unterschied.
Ja, du sprichst natürlich da leicht ironisch ein wichtiges Feld an. Du machst ja nichts richtig und bist sowieso der größte Depp mit der wenigsten Ahnung überhaupt. Wie ist denn das, wenn man so in der Öffentlichkeit steht und vor allem negative Kritik abbekommt?
Es ist Part of the Game. Ganz einfach. Damit müssen wir uns alle... Also es liegt ja in der Natur der Sache, ich kann nicht mehr als 50 Prozent der Zuschauer für mich einnehmen. Und von diesen 50 Prozent finden mich 25 auch wieder beschissen. Weil der eine hat die Farbe rot, der andere hat die Farbe blau. So, was soll ich dann tun? Meine Aufgabe ist das, meine Meinung auf das Spiel zu geben. Und ich gebe meine Meinung. Und dass die nicht immer richtig ist, dass die vielleicht nicht immer jedem gefällt, so what?
Also da habe ich zum Beispiel sehr spannende, interessante Beispiele. Hin und wieder treibe ich mich ja in den sozialen Netzwerken rum. Und es ist immer wahnsinnig interessant, wenn man dann bei Nachspielen bei Facebook unterwegs ist. Zunächst mal Premier League und La Liga, das ist schon mal wie Arte und RTL 2. Das zum einen. Kommentierst du spanische Spiele, kannst du entweder – oder nee, du machst entweder alles richtig oder alles falsch, weil auf der linken Seite hast du die Messi-Basta-Jünger und auf der rechten Seite hast du die Cristiano Ronaldo-Real Madrid-Jünger. Wenn du was Positives über Messi sagst, bist du für die Barca-Fans der Beste und die Real-Fans werfen dir also wirklich alles vor. Insofern kannst du in dem Bereich, wenn du spanische Spiele kommentierst oder als Experte begleitest, im Prinzip nur alles falsch machen, weil die Hälfte hast du immer gegen dich. Ansonsten hilft es tatsächlich, und die Erfahrung habe ich jetzt häufiger gemacht, wenn du die Leute, die dann auf eine gewisse Art und Weise kritisieren, die oftmals nicht nachvollziehbar ist, nicht der Inhalt, sondern die Form, wenn du einfach sagst, du, hier bin ich, ich war derjenige, der deiner Meinung nach nur Scheiße erzählt hat, worum geht es denn? Und in 95 Prozent aller Fälle kommt dann als Antwort, ja, nee, so war das ja eigentlich nicht gemeint, aber das und das fand ich vielleicht doch nicht so cool. Wo ich dann sage, das ist auch in Ordnung, das ist eine Kritik, mit der können wir auch durchaus umgehen. Wenn mir einer schreibt, das war kein Foul, das sehe ich anders, ist in Ordnung. Aber du laberst nur Scheiße, ist halt relativ – darf ich das eigentlich sagen? Ist halt nicht so viel Substanz.
Hat der tief in die Augen geguckt, als er gesagt hat, du laberst nur Scheiße.
Das ist mir aufgefallen. Dafür gebe ich ihm die nächste Spezies nicht aus. Da bin ich knallhart. Wie viel Vorbereitung steckst du denn zeitmäßig in so 90 Minuten Übertragung? Kann man das überhaupt übers Knie brechen?
Ja, kann man. Also weniger als acht Stunden sind selten. Das ist tatsächlich ziemlich genau. Ich werde ja für den Tag bezahlt. Das ist durchaus über die Woche normal.
Alte Spiele gucken, Statistiken wechseln?
Ja, das kommt ein bisschen darauf an. Alte Spiele gucke ich vor allen Dingen dann, wenn ich die Mannschaften, die Liga noch nicht so gut kenne, in der Premier League, wo ich mehr oder weniger in meinem natürlichen Lebensraum bin, muss ich das nicht mehr so sehr tun. Aber wir kriegen Statistikmappen angeliefert, die sind mehr oder weniger umfangreich. Im Grunde gilt, je schwächer das Spiel, umso weniger auch der Support, je stärker das Spiel, umso mehr. Und dann geht das ganz klassisch von, was ich vorhin mal kurz angesprochen habe, Fanforen, einfach um eine Meinung zu kriegen, Twitterfans, um eine Meinung zu bekommen. Dann geht es über sämtliche Zeitungsquellen, sowohl der sportliche Teil der ganzen Veranstaltung, als auch vor allen Dingen der Gossip. Das muss ich eben auch mit tun, auch wenn ich es jetzt nicht so gerne mag, aber auch das hat der Zuschauer verdient. Und dann telefoniere ich eine ganze Menge, mache mir immer wieder Notizen. Ich habe zu Hause ordnerweise Aufzeichnungen über sämtliche Teams. Die gehe ich auch nochmal alle durch, damit ich zwar nicht immer dasselbe erzähle, aber zumindest den Gedankengang noch vor Augen habe oder mir mal eine Notiz in einem Spiel gemacht hat, der macht wahnsinnig viel über Links. Oder wenn Ralph mal was Kluges sagt, dann mache ich mir eine kleine Notiz dazu. Und auch das gehe ich nochmal durch.
Und wie ordnest du das dann beim Spiel? Also ich kenne Kommentatoren, die nehmen da Karteikarten mit. Es gibt Leute, die sitzen da mit ihren DIN A4-Zetteln. Ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt schon häufiger gefragt, warum man das nicht digital macht, wo man ja sehr schnell seine Notizen auch durchsuchen kann. Wie machst du das?
Auch tatsächlich sehr traditionell mit der Hand. Fritz hat mir irgendwann mal beigebracht, auch da, du merkst, ich vertraue den Menschen und er hat mich dahin gebracht, wo ich jetzt bin. Daher hat er auch Recht dazu. Eine Seite maximal handgeschrieben ist. Da steht links Heimmannschaft, rechts Gastmannschaft. In der Mitte das, was beide betrifft. Und den Rest male ich mir auf Spielerkärtchen, die wir vom Statistikdienst bekommen. Da male ich mir dann den Gossip mit drauf. Da male ich mir noch Superstatistik, extra Statistik mit drauf. Manchmal schreibe ich noch auf die Rückseite auf der einen Seite. Aber mehr als eine Seite gibt es nicht bei mir. Versuche ich immer, wenn es geht, nicht machen zu müssen.
Was ich sehr häufig im Rasenfunk selbst erlebe, ist, trotz aller akribischen Vorbereitung und egal, wie viel Arbeit man steckt, manchmal sogar je mehr Arbeit man reinsteckt in die Vorbereitung, desto häufiger passiert es mir, dass ich Blackouts habe. Meistens bezieht sich das auf Vornamen von Spielern lustigerweise. Also Rasenfunk-Enter könnten in Zukunft mal darauf achten, wenn ich nur den Nachnamen sage und vorher so eine halbe Sekunde stocke, dann ist mir kurz der Vornamen entfallen. Hast du so etwas? Und wenn nicht, kannst du mir das Geheimnis verraten, wie das geht?
Ich würde nicht von mir behaupten wollen, dass ich das nie habe, aber zu 99 Prozent habe ich es nicht, weil das sprechende Volk unter uns Journalisten dazu ausgebildet ist, dass ihr die Verzögerungslaute wie M, R oder weiß ich nicht einfach nicht hört. Ich hoffe, dass ich in diesem Podcast, das müsste man mal wissenschaftlich nachzählen, maximal auf fünf R's komme.
Aber hast du auch dieses, dass dir mal kurz eine Information entfällt, bei der du dir so zu 90 Prozent sicher bist, eigentlich stimmt das so, aber man will es ja dann ohnehin doch nicht sagen.
Es gibt sogar ein ganz prominentes Beispiel, das ging auch wirklich durch Deutschland. Aufstiegspiel, Zweite Liga, England, Huddersfield gegen M, jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, Redding. Und da wollte ich den Fakt bringen, das habe ich mir so überlegt, wenn Huddersfield aufsteigt, keine Ahnung wie die Zahl ist, seit so und so vielen Tagen sind sie jetzt endlich wieder in der ersten Liga zurück. Glaubst du, ich hätte die scheiß Zahl noch gefunden? No way. Ich glaube, also für mich ist das sehr schlimm, wenn ich das heute noch höre. Ich glaube aber, dass der Zuschauer das gar nicht so wahrnimmt. Ich habe angefangen im Radio, da ist jede geschwiegende Sekunde eine Stunde.
Ja, das stimmt. Das habt ihr jetzt nicht gehört, aber das hat man auch im Intro zu dieser Folge gehört. Da habe ich nämlich hintereinander geschnitten. Du als Fritz von Ton und Taxis Jünger wirst es bestimmt kennen. Ich habe das Finale 3 zu 2 Tor im WM-Finale 1966 in seiner Kommentierung reingeschnitten. Da wurden quasi nur die Namen genannt. Und dahinter habe ich, zugegeben als krassestmöglichen Kontrast, den isländischen Kommentatorband 2-2-1 gegen England bei dieser Helm geschnitten. Das sind ja so die zwei Arten von Emotionen, die man haben kann.
Aber sind wir auch mal ehrlich, wenn das Spiel gut ist und wenn das Thema des Spiels so erdrückend ist, dann muss ich nur hui hui hui schreien und dann sagen alle, du hast super gesprochen.
Ja, aber die Realität ist ja auch. Ich meine, ich habe es mal so überschlagen. Ich habe wahrscheinlich so um die 120 bis 130 Bundesligaspiele über die volle Zeit gesehen in der letzten Saison. Die Wahrheit ist, die meisten Spiele sind eher schlecht und langweilig. Was macht man denn da, Ralph?
Da bin ich natürlich in der großartigen Situation, einfach Uli angucken zu können und zu sagen, mach mal, der Kommentar ist dein Job. Das ist halt wirklich ein ganz elementarer Unterschied zwischen unseren beiden Aufgaben. Ich habe auch schon Spiele gehabt, nachts um 2.30 Uhr, WM-Qualifikation, Bolivien gegen Argentinien, was vom Namen her großartig klingt, und dann spielen die eine Rotze, dass du halt echt froh bist, einfach nur gucken und dich berieseln zu lassen und hast fast Mitleid mit deinem Kommentator, weil der muss am Ball bleiben, der muss machen. Ich steige halt ein, wenn was passiert, wenn irgendwas auffällig ist. Und ansonsten drücke ich die Daumen, dass mein Kollege nebenan das irgendwie über die Reihe oder auf die Reihe bekommt. Da habe ich den einfacheren, den entspannteren Job.
Wie schlecht muss ein Spiel sein, dass du wirklich sagen darfst, dass es ein schlechtes Spiel ist? Bist du Verkäufer eines Fußballspiels?
Ja, bin ich. Keine Frage. Ich blaue dir jetzt aus dem Nähkästchen, das wird nicht vielleicht meinen Job kosten, aber alle Sender, für die es sich meiner Meinung nach lohnt, als Kommentator zu arbeiten, sind Pay-TV-Sender. Das bedeutet, das ganze Produkt funktioniert nur, wenn der Kunde auch zahlt. Der Kunde ist in dem Fall der Zuschauer, nicht despektierlich gemeint. Wenn ich dem Kunden sage, das ist alles Müll, dann bin ich alleine und habe ja noch viel weniger Lust drauf. Das heißt, ich versuche, und das ist die große Aufgabe, und das macht den guten Kommentator im Unterschied zum schlechten Kommentator aus. Meine Aufgabe ist es, zu sagen, warum das schlecht ist, und nicht das ist schlecht. Das sieht der Zuschauer selbst. Und, by the way, auch da noch mal, man muss auch ein bisschen demütig an die Sache rangehen. Egal, wie schlecht die spielen in der Premier League Bundesliga, das sind immer noch verdammte Profis. Und deshalb kann es so schlecht nicht sein, wie die Grütze, die ich zusammenkicken würde. Auch das muss man immer im Hinterkopf haben.
Plus, wenn ich kurz reingretchen darf, das ist dann wieder auch sehr interessant. Ich erinnere mich an das Spiel Manchester United gegen Liverpool, was auf den ersten Blick kein gutes Spiel war. Liverpool zu Hause, Entschuldigung, Liverpool United. Das war kein gutes Spiel auf den ersten Blick. Auf den zweiten Blick war es taktisch einfach ein wahnsinnig interessantes Spiel, weil Mourinho ein paar Stachzüge seiner Mannschaft mitgegeben hat, die Liverpool komplett den Zahn gezogen haben. Die haben das Spiel uninteressant gemacht im Sinne von wenig Highlights, aber es war auf sehr, sehr hohem Niveau. Und da sehe ich dann meine Aufgabe zu erklären, warum ist das jetzt in dem Moment richtig gut, dass Pogba, der bis dahin sehr tief stand, in diesem Spiel fast auf der Zehn gespielt hat, Henderson komplett gestört hat im Spielaufbau, und da haben sie Liverpool halt wirklich in der eigenen Hälfte vor große Probleme gestellt. Es ist natürlich auf eine eigene Art und Weise ein interessantes Spiel. Es ist kein Spektakel und für den neutralen Zuschauer vielleicht nicht spannend. Aber mit dem, was ich ihm dann mitgebe, sagt er vielleicht, boah, das war ja gar nicht so dumm vom Trainer, oder wieder was dazugelernt, wieder, ok, wenn ich jetzt so einen Mann habe und schiebe den vor, schaffe mindestens Gleichzahl, dann passiert genau das und schon hat der Zuschauer was gelernt und ich finde es gut.
Und wie ist das jetzt bei Spielen? Ich erinnere mich da an so manches Ingolstadt-Lewakusenspiel oder so in der letzten Bundesliga-Saison, wo ich mir gedacht habe, ich sehe hier klappt irgendwas nicht, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was eigentlich der Plan dahinter gewesen sein sollte. Es ist einfach nur ein wildes Durcheinander. Hast du das auch manchmal?
Apropos wildes Durcheinander, kriegen wir es nochmal hin, fünf Minuten ein bisschen die Lautstärke runterzudrehen? Ah, herrlich.
Vor allem die Leute, die das gerade als Podcast hören.
Danke. Ähm, da bin ich jetzt mal so wie Uli eben, mit den zu 99 Prozent passiert ihm das nicht. Ich behaupte, 99 Prozent aller Fälle erkenne ich, was der eigentliche Plan ist. Und es gibt immer Gründe, warum der nicht funktioniert. Und da profitiere ich dann einfach, und das ist vielleicht auch der Unterschied, da profitiere ich von meiner Erfahrung. Und zum Beispiel ein ganz konkretes Beispiel, was das Wechselspiel zwischen Experte und Kommentator eigentlich bedeutet. Ähm, kurz vor der Zone war ich schon für Marco Haggemann seine Soufflöse quasi. Also wenn die die Nationalmannschaft, die Länderspiele kommentieren, haben die einen Experten an der Seite, den man aber nicht hört. So und das war das Spiel in Schottland. Schottland spielt mit einer Sechserkette in der ersten Halbzeit. Und in der Halbzeit wird umgestellt auf Viererkette. Zweite Halbzeit dauerte 30 Sekunden und ich habe es erkannt, weil ich halt aus eigener Erfahrung weiß, wie man sich dann verhält. Und habe ihm nur durchgegeben, pass auf, umgestellt auf Viererkette, stehen 10 Meter höher. Es gibt Platz zwischen Abwehr und Torhüter. Zehn Minuten später steht Thomas Müller genau in diesem Raum, schiebt den Ball quer und das Tor 2-0. Und Marco stellt sich hin und erklärt dann, liebe Zuschauer, die Schotten haben in der Halbzeit umgestellt auf Viererkette. Es gab mehr Raum im Rücken der Abwehr, das sehen wir hier in der Wiederholung. Und das haben die Deutschen clever genutzt. Und du sitzt daneben und denkst dir, ach so, ja gut, dann verkauf du das. Ich bin ja dein Assistent, weil bei RTL ist es ja so, dass man die Assistenten nicht hört. Warum eigentlich?
Warum gibt es das heutzutage nicht mehr so häufig?
Das ist eine Philosophiefrage, da müssten wir ja, ich weiß nicht, haben wir jemanden, der bei Sky arbeitet? Wo ist er denn? Ja, nicht du. Wo ist denn der, Stefan? Der ist rauchen. Nein, das ist tatsächlich eine Philosophiegeschichte. Das zieht sich durch ARD, ZDF, Sky, Eurosport, Sport1. Das wird einfach nicht gemacht im Ausland gang und gäbe. Zum Teil die Dänen zum Beispiel bei der Europameisterschaft, mit zwei Experten neben den. Das hat Hannu Balic, der ja der Assistent für Belaredi ist. Die hatten die Dänen neben sich, die saßen da zu dritt und haben das Spiel entsprechend kommentiert. Das müsstest du die Verantwortlichen fragen. Hat sich hier so durchgesetzt, das alleine zu machen? Die Zone hat entschieden, das machen wir anders. Ich persönlich bin da sehr froh drum.
Es ist für den Konsumenten sehr viel angenehmer, Spiele zu sehen, gerade die schlechten Spiele. Da merkt man auch manchmal, dass sich Experte und Kommentator gegenseitig retten über das, was man auf dem Platz sehen muss. Jetzt warst du ja vorher als Profi-Spieler unterwegs und hattest ja da auch schon immer mit Journalisten und Experten, sogenannten Experten auch zu tun. Hat sich was an deinem Verhältnis zu TV-Experten geändert, dadurch, dass du es jetzt selber machen musst? Hast du irgendwas unterschätzt an ihrer Tätigkeit?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht in ihrer Tätigkeit unterschätzt, aber ich habe einen neuen Blick auf die Sache bekommen. Also ich bin ja dann eine Stunde, eineinhalb, bevor das Spiel losgeht, bin ich ja auch da und bin dann im Regierraum und sehe, die hören sich dann die Match-Interviews mit den Trainern an. In England werden die ja kurz vorm Spiel nochmal relativ ausführlich interviewt. Und bekomme dann mit, wie redaktionell auf Interviews geschaut wird, wie Trainer wahrgenommen werden, wie Aussagen wahrgenommen werden. Und das ist halt interessant, jetzt die andere Seite zu sehen. Und da ich momentan an meinem Trainerschein arbeite und vielleicht irgendwann mal wieder auf der anderen Seite sitze, hilft mir das, denke ich, dass ich auch die journalistische Seite kenne und genau einschätzen kann, wie Dinge aufgenommen werden.
Das heißt, du hast gerade angekündigt, dass du irgendwann Bundesligisten trainieren wirst?
Das kannst du genauso wenig planen wie die Spielerkarriere, aber ich werde zumindest meine Lizenzen machen und dann schauen wir mal.
Ich wette mit dir, dann wäre es hier leiser, wenn du einen Bundesligisten trainieren würdest. Aber daran arbeiten wir jetzt einfach gemeinsam und dann lade ich dich nochmal ein. Was war denn so der größte Bock, den der Ralph mal geschossen hat in der Übertragung mit dir? Uns hörte hier eh niemand zu. Kannst du dir einfach erzählen.
Lustigerweise genau einer, das ist der einzige, der mir einfällt. Vielleicht war es auch der eine hier tatsächlich.
Du kannst auch später noch ein paar andere erzählen.
Ralph ist auf Twitter, wie wir alle wissen. Und Ralph ist eigentlich immer auf Twitter.
Hat er während des Spiels getwittert?
Ja. Was aber cool ist. Klar, machen wir alle. Ich hätte das gerne. Ich würde mir manchmal wünschen, dass ich mich wirklich mal eine Minute zurücklehne und beispielsweise was twittere. Ich weiß im Übrigen gar nicht, ob es daran gelegen hat.
In dem Fall nein, aber erzähl mal.
Das war lustigerweise noch ausgewählt für eine Schulung von einem Wissenschaftler, der Einzige, der sich in Deutschland mit Kommentierung beschäftigt. Vorlauf, es war insgesamt eine sehr schlechte Sendung von allen Beteiligten. Ich habe irgendetwas dahergeschwurbelt und habe dann gemerkt, du bist schon in einer Ausfahrt, vergiss es, leg ihm was hin. Wir hatten uns vorher abgesprochen, dass ich ihn dann angucke, so sehr scheinschwanger, und er dann was sagt. Dann gucke ich ihn an und er hat sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, was hat er da gerade erzählt? Ich habe auch gerade noch überlegt, das habe ich gerade erzählt. Dann haben wir uns beide angeschaut, 30 Sekunden Schweigen. Und er greift zu mir, geht die Frage an mich. Da habe ich überlegt, war das überhaupt eine Frage? Nein, das waren eigentlich keine Fragen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich glaube schon. Dann habe ich irgendeinen Schwachsinn erzählt, damit es nicht so auffällt. Und da war einfach mal 30 Sekunden Schweigen. Und ich glaube, die Leute um uns rum, die dann in der Gallery sitzen, die waren auch leicht überfordert. Weil normalerweise kommen sofort aufs Ohr, was ist da? Und die haben einfach auch nichts gesagt dazu. Das ist genau die Regie, wo dann die Leute, die wirklich arbeiten, sitzen und die ganze Sendung bauen. Das sind beide Sauen meistens so sieben bis acht.
Willst du mit einem Bock von ihm gegenhalten?
Da waren viele.
Ein Bock von Uli. Mir fällt da ganz konkret wirklich nichts. Also die eine Geschichte vielleicht noch inhaltlich als Aufklärung. Es ging um eine Grafik zum Thema Bilanz gegen Cossi Mourinho von Arsene Wenger. Das war das Spiel United gegen Arsenal. Und er hat mich was zu dieser Grafik, die da halt lief, gefragt. Und ich war aber im Kopf bei einer komplett anderen Grafik, die vorher drauf war. Und ich habe noch Zusammenhänge gesucht. Und dann fragt er mich und ich gucke ihn an. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon du redest. Und das war halt live. Aber, mein Gott, das ist tatsächlich mal passiert. Ansonsten, ein Bock von Uli, weiß ich nicht, hast du mal Spieler verwechselt?
Ja, bestimmt mal. Bestimmt.
Aber ansonsten...
Meistens korrigiere ich das dann aber, weil das ist auch okay.
Von wem kriegt man denn da eigentlich Feedback nach so einer Sendung?
Von allen.
Von allen?
Ja, ja, von allen.
Was heißt denn hier alle?
Wie wir gehört haben, von jedem einzelnen Zuschauer. Witzigerweise, wann immer ich abends unterwegs bin, habe ich das Trikot-Kommentator an und muss erstmal eine Menge erzählen, was ich auch irgendwie gerne tue, weil für viele ist das einfach ein emotionaler Punkt. Das berührt die.
Ja, aber wie du hast das Trikot-Kommentator an?
Naja, also in dem Moment, wo man mich fragt, was arbeitest du denn?
Ach so, nicht sinnbildlich.
Nicht sinnbildlich. Wenn man mich fragt, was arbeitest du denn, dann sage ich so etwas wie Journalist. Und dann wird es, je nachdem, manche sind dann schon raus. Und manche sagen dann, ja, was denn genau? Und dann sage ich beim Fernsehen, ja, und was denn genau? So, und in dem Moment, das verstehe ich auch, hat jeder das Bedürfnis, mal dem Kommentator zu sagen, wie scheiße er eigentlich diese Gattung findet. Das ist auch okay, das höre ich mir dann auch gerne an. Gehe aber dann auch mit dem Referat dazwischen. So ist es nicht. Und, aber ich sage dir ehrlich, es macht wenig Sinn, sich auf, es hat jeder, auch Kollege für dich, Ratschläge. Es gibt zwei, drei Menschen, auf die ich wirklich höre, deren Feedback mir wirklich sehr wichtig ist, wo ich auch vor allen Dingen weiß, dass sie mir nicht sagen, Mensch, das war wieder granatenartig, sondern die mir wirklich meistens nur sagen, ach, die hast du aber echt mal verwechselt. Oder da hast du mal wieder Close rutschen lassen, wenn du dich neu erinnerst.
Und es ist jetzt aber nicht so wie bei den Schiedsrichtern, dass ihr ein Punktesystem habt, nach dem ihr dann auf und ab steigt, oder?
Auch das gibt's. Also Sky bewertet tatsächlich so. Die haben über die Jahre tatsächlich etwas erarbeitet, wo du mehr oder weniger messbar machen kannst, wer wie gut ist. Da schauen dann verschiedene Instanzen drüber zu verschiedenen Zeitpunkten der Saison. Und dann wird über die Saison hinweg ein kleines Ranking erstellt. Das gibt's tatsächlich.
Das ist ja verrückt. Und das ist intern sichtbar. Kann man aber öffentlich nicht ansehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das intern sichtbar ist. Ich habe es bislang nicht gesehen, aber mir hat der Kommentatorenchef auch gesagt, ich darf das gerne auch in die Öffentlichkeit tragen. Die schauen sehr stark darauf, wie ihre Kommentatoren arbeiten.
Ist es da wichtig, wie du auch bei solchen Auftritten hier, aber auch in den sozialen Netzwerken auftrittst? Denn du bist ja immer auch ein bisschen Sprecher für deinen Sender.
Das ist das, was ich meine. Ich habe das Trikot an, ob ich will oder nicht. Und ich bin als freier Mitarbeiter auch darauf angewiesen, dass man mich weiterhin einsetzt. Und ich kann mich nicht davon freimachen. Für die meisten Menschen, wenn dir die DAZN-App nicht funktioniert, dann bin ich der Erste, den sie anschreiben, weil ich bin der Sichtbarste, wenn du so willst. Ralph genauso, spielt keine Rolle.
Ja, ihr habt das Ding ja auch programmiert.
Daher natürlich. Ich muss aufpassen, was ich in der Öffentlichkeit sage, über wen ich was sage. Du kannst es dir im Journalismus nicht leisten und du solltest es dir, by the way, auch nicht leisten, über Kollegen herzuziehen, weil es einfach kein guter Stil ist, wenn dann sagst du es denen bitte persönlich. Also natürlich.
Ich würde sagen, damit haben wir schon viel über euch erfahren. Noch mehr erfahren wir im zweiten Teil, in dem es dann eure Zuschauerfragen gibt zu Hörerfragen. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie sich das mit dem Lärmpegel entwickelt. Aber zunächst bitte ich erstmal schon mal für einen tosenden Applaus für die beiden und wir sehen uns in einer Viertelstunde.
Vielen Dank.
So, ich begrüße euch zum zweiten Teil, zur zweiten Halbzeit dieses Rasenfunk-Lives. Es freut mich vor allem für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer an den Empfangsgeräten und den Weltempfängern da draußen, die drangeblieben sind. Ihr verpasst es hier zu sein in einem Raum mit gefühlten 120 Grad Temperatur und das liegt ganz alleine an meinen beiden Gästen, nämlich Ralph Gunesch und Uli Hebel. Vielen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei seid und euch jetzt auch den Hörerinnen und Hörern Fragen stellt. Ich muss ein bisschen aussortieren, so viel Wahrheit muss sein, aber das ist nicht bei mir zu suchen, die Schuld dafür. Erste Frage, Uli, die gebe ich mal an dich. Wie viel Anteil hat subjektives Kommentieren und wie viel hat objektive Beschreibung und ist dieser Anteil planbar?
100% subjektiv kann nur so sein, weil das, was ich tue, ist kommentieren und die Gattung des Kommentierens erfordert, dass ich meinen Senf dazu gebe. Nicht das, was ihr seht, das wäre dann der, soweit das irgend geht, objektive Teil, aber das, was ich mache, ist zu 100% subjektiv. Kann gar nicht anders sein, geht nicht anders.
Und wie viel ist da von der Beschreibung detailliert? Denn da, finde ich, gibt es schon Unterschiede zwischen Kommentatoren. Es gibt Leute, da hat man fast den Eindruck, die kommen aus dem Radio, die beschreiben sehr sehr viel, sagen auch sehr sehr viele Spielernamen und es gibt Leute, die lassen das viel mehr laufen.
Der gute Fernsehkommentator beschreibt de facto gar nicht. Der ist hinter dem Bild. Sagt man immer so schön. Das heißt, ihr alle seht selber, dass der Ball drin war, ihr alle seht selber, dass das ein Pass war, dass das über die rechte Seite geht, dass es eine Flanke ist, dass der Ball drüber ging etc. Das ist nicht meine Aufgabe, sondern ich muss die Ebene da drunter gehen und Ralph dann noch zwei drunter, indem wir erklären, ist das gut, ist das schlecht, bewerten, das ist mal Aufgabe Nummer eins, dann sicherlich auch dazu informieren und dann vielleicht nochmal irgendwie in die taktische Analyse gehen, in die Fehleranalyse gehen etc. Aber richtig, es gibt viele, die vom Radio ins Fernsehen gehen, dazu gehöre ich auch. Du glaubst nicht, wie oft mir Fritz von Ton und Taxis gesagt hat, Junge, hör auf zu beschreiben. Das habe ich mir dann irgendwann per Zettelchen, das mache ich auch immer noch im Übrigen ganz klein, irgendwo hingemerkt, damit ich mache ja auch beide Disziplinen nach wie vor, gerne auch Radio, damit ich nicht von einem in das andere wechsle, mache ich mir immer so einen kleinen Denkzettel sozusagen und das Gehirn ist ja schlau genug oder doof genug, wie man das möchte, dass das dann auch unterbewusst auf sowas reagiert.
Und was ist anstrengender, Radio-Kommentar oder TV-Kommentar?
Ja, Radio, viel anstrengender. Also wenn ich 90 Minuten Radio hinter mir habe, dann möchte ich keinen mehr sehen, wenn ich 90 Minuten Fernsehen hinter mir habe, dann würde ich ganz gerne noch eins machen.
Aber du machst ja 90 Minuten nicht allein im Radio, oder?
Doch. Doch, 90 Minuten Vollreportage am Stück. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Die sitzen zu viert im Stadion mit fünf Kablern und – hast du nicht gesehen? Und ich sitze alleine und muss sogar noch meinen Player aufbauen. Also ich bin allein im Radio tatsächlich. Von A bis Z auch im Vorlauf, in der Halbzeit, im Nachlauf. Ich bin to sure nonstop zwei Stunden am Stück auf Sendung. Und zwar, das habe ich dir vorhin gesagt, ich darf mir zwei Sekunden Schwarz hören nicht erlauben. Ich muss sprechen.
Und wie viel trinkst du dabei und was trinkst du dabei? Wir haben auch eine Frage nach einem Bierkonsum gestellt bekommen während TV-Übertragung.
Das kommt schon mal vor.
Ich dachte, Getränke mit Kronensäure darf man nicht.
Sollte man nicht, aber hast du mir ja auch hier hergestellt und es geht. Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen die Faden verloren. Also Bierkonsum, das lasse ich dann Ralph, weil wir sprechen in derselben Sache in dem Fall. Während des Radiospiels trinke ich gar nichts, weil es nicht geht. Kann ich einfach nicht. In der Halbzeit saube ich dann und gehe aufs Klo. Nein, das geht. Ich könnte euch die Technik jetzt vormachen, aber ich will nicht, dass das Bild bei Twitter landet. Es gibt natürlich verschiedene Techniken, wie wir unsere Kehlen befeuchtet.
Ich glaube, das ist eh schon ganz gut hier mit den Mikros, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, gut, nach Bier muss ich nicht fragen. Aber wenn Uli die Getränkefrage schon an dich weiterreicht, dann wirft das viele Anschlussfragen auf. Wie viel wird getrunken, wenn so Live-Übertragungen?
Also dadurch, dass unsere Studios gut klimatisiert sind, entstehen nicht solche Temperaturen, also wenn ich jetzt so überlege, mein Getränkekonsum meistens stilles Wasser. Und mit meinen Kommentatoren, das ist so ein halber Liter, zum Teil bis zwei Liter pro Spiel.
Aber Ralph, das müssen wir auch sagen, hat mich auch bei der Sonne auf die Schokomilch gebracht. Da steht ein Automat mit Schokomilch. Und Ralph hat mir irgendwann mal so nach zwei Monaten gesagt, hast du schon mal die Schokomilch probiert? Bis dato habe ich immer Schoko-Chino getrunken. Und jetzt Schokomilch.
Also in den Wintermonaten war das sehr angenehm. Bei den Temperaturen ist es wirklich stilles Wasser, manchmal auch Multivitaminsaft, aber wie du eben schon dachtest, keine Kohlensäure. Und das variiert wirklich von Kommentator zu Kommentator. Ein halber Liter geht immer weg. Also wir haben halt 0, 5er Flatschen, bis hin zu 1, 5, 2 Liter.
Also erst mal muss ich sagen, dass ihr ein wirklich süßes Pärchen seid, wie ihr jetzt gerade hier mit der Schokomilch-Anekdote rausgelassen habt. Würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn Hashtag Schokomilch trendet. Über das ganze Wochenende wahrscheinlich.
Aber die ist wirklich gut. Ist zwar aus dem Automaten, aber es schmeckt.
Wie man sieht.
Ja, die Hörerinnen und Hörer da draußen ja nicht. Wie kommentiert ihr denn eigentlich? Im Sitzen oder im Stehen und was ist besser?
Also zu 99 Prozent im Sitzen natürlich. Sitzplatzschweine. Ich muss gestehen, es gibt Situationen, es gibt Geschichten, wo ich einfach dann aufstehe, weil ich mich furchtbar über das Verhalten auf dem Platz aufrege, weil ich sage, wie kannst du nur?
Gibt es das auch, wenn du dich freust oder bist du jemand, wenn du stehst, dann ärgerst du dich?
Ich stelle mich dann hin, wenn ich mich ärgere, wenn es so ganz dumme Situationen sind, wo du genau weißt, also natürlich kenne ich die auch als Spieler, aber du weißt halt auch, die hätte man ganz einfach verhindern können und dann hättest du das Spiel eben nicht verloren. Und das regt mich dann furchtbar auf, muss dann allerdings aufpassen, dass ich nicht zu weit vom Tisch weg gehe, weil das Kabel ist ja auch nur begrenzt lang. Wir haben ja beides das Aufstiegsspiel kommentiert jetzt mit Huddersfield. Ich glaube, ich stand beim Elfmeterschießen.
Ich habe auch gerade überlegt, das war auch das erste, was mir in den Sinn geschossen ist. Ich könnte euch nicht mehr sagen, ob ich gestanden oder gelegen bin oder... In dem Moment, und das ist dann... In dem Moment kommst du so in das Nirvana, wo du als Kommentator im Idealfall bist, wo du alles rund um dich herum vergisst und echt nur noch beim Spiel bist. Und witzigerweise sind das auch dann die Szenen oder die Spiele, die auch den Hörern, Zuschauern am meisten in den Köpfen bleiben, weil sie einfach merken, okay, in ihm ist echt was passiert.
Also vielleicht nur, um das mal einzuordnen. Das war das Aufstiegsfinal in Wembley, das ist der Championship in die Premier League. Bei diesem Spiel ging es um – Uli, wir haben es ein paar Mal erwähnt – 289 Millionen Pfund bis hin zu 380 Millionen Pfund. Also es sind ein paar Euro bzw. Ich versuche mir das vorzustellen, wenn du als Spieler im Tunnel stehst und weißt, du gehst jetzt raus und das kriegst du mit. Und das kriegst du auch von den Vereinsverantwortlichen gesagt, um was es in diesem Spiel geht. So und dann war einfach diese Dramaturgie dieses Spiels, dass es halt zum Elfmeterschießen kommt. Und dann bist du komplett drin in diesem Spiel und gehst mit und ich stand. Ich bin da sehr, sehr behauptlich sachlich professionell. Das würde ich auch sogar beim HSV hinkriegen, privat Null. Aber als Kommentator würde ich das oder als Co-Kommentator würde ich es hinkriegen, auch den HSV professionell zu kommentieren. Aber trotzdem bist du im Spiel einfach drin, weil es ein besonderes Spiel war. Wenn ich noch das kurz erzählen darf, ich hatte das große Glück in Barcelona zu sein, live im Stadion beim Spiel gegen Paris. Gut, dass ich das nicht kommentieren musste, weil selbst auf der Tribüne als Neutraler, mir persönlich war völlig egal, wer da weiterkommt. Ich wollte einfach ein schönes Spiel sehen, war froh im Stadion zu sein, mir war das wirklich völlig glatt, wer da weiterkommt. Und dann sitzt du die letzten Minuten auf der Tribüne und ich war sprachlos. Ich wusste nicht, keine Ahnung, ich habe überlegt, wenn ich jetzt kommentieren würde, ich wüsste nicht, was ich erzählen soll, weil dieses Spiel einfach, die meisten haben wahrscheinlich alles gesehen, es ist nicht zu beschreiben. Uli, ich weiß ja nicht, was würdest du machen, du würdest?
Ich nenne ein anderes Beispiel, der Kollege kommt nie gut weg, da kann man darüber streiten, ich finde ihn gar nicht so schlecht, wie er immer gemacht wird. Halbfinale Deutschland-Brasilien 7.1, glaube ich, hat jeder für immer vor Augen und Kopf und im Herzen. Besser geht es nicht. Also das nehme ich immer wieder auch als Lehrbeispiel her, weil es gibt im Journalismus – ich will jetzt nicht zu viel erzählen, aber das ist, glaube ich, auch sehr schnell begreifbar – die alte Regel, je größer sozusagen das, was passiert, je größer das Event, die Tragödie, wie auch immer, umso weniger Wort brauchst du. Umso weniger musst du auch dick auftragen. Deswegen lesen wir täglich den ganzen Quatsch, der in verschiedenen Zeitungen mit vier Buchstaben davor kommt, wo dann sensationalisiert wird. Im Gegenteil ist dann im Umkehrschluss das der Fall, dass das anders sein muss. Und was geht denn hier ab? Und dann auch sehr respektvoll damit umzugehen. Ich hoffe, dass mir das in so einem Fall gelingen würde, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, aber das finde ich ein ganz interessantes Beispiel, denn da gab es mal eine längere Untersuchung von, ich glaube, Sprachwissenschaftlern, die den BBC-Kommentar dazu analysiert haben, der, wie ich finde, immer noch einer der großartigsten Live-Kommentare aller Zeiten ist, denn die haben es geschafft, diese Situation, so schwierig es war, in sprachliche Bilder zu kleiden. Also ich weiß nur, nach dem 2 zu 0 haben sie gesagt, und jetzt haben sie eine Berge, die sie kleiden.
Ja, man muss aber dazu wissen, der deutsche Kommentar ist der sich am meisten unterscheidenste im Vergleich zu allen anderen Ländern.
Warum?
Weil du kannst auf der linken Seite in eine Ecke, also ich hab nichts gegen die Linken, weder politisch noch sonst irgendwas, kannst du den Deutschen stellen, da darfst du nämlich nicht reden. Da sollst du möglichst den Zuschauer sehen lassen und das Spiel atmen lassen. Und in allen anderen Ländern dieser Welt heißt es, hau raus, was du hast. Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. Der Engländer beschreibt wahnsinnig viel. Der Engländer akzeptiert auch Floskeln in Anführungszeichen eher, weil die englische Sprache nicht ganz so difícil ist. Dagegen, wenn einer meiner Kommentierungsstudenten floskelt, dann zahlt er in eine Kasse ein. Der Gegner von allen Journalisten sollten benutzte Formulierungen sein. Und wir leben in einer Welt von lauter benutzten Formulierungen. Und wenn jetzt jemand sagen wird, in einem wie auch immer gearteten Spiel, jetzt müssen sie aber noch den Berg hochlaufen, dann sage ich, bitte schön etwas kreativer, weil das habe ich halt schon ein paar Mal gehört und gelesen.
Ja, faszinierend aber, wie unterschiedlich das ausgelegt wird. Findest du, dass das manchmal zu wenig Emotionen ist? Also ich hatte lange Zeit, in der Zeit, in der ich noch eher so rumänische Streams konsumiert habe zum Sound von Fußball. Natürlich war das lange bevor das jetzt noch irgendwie justiziabel wäre. Ich erinnere mich aber nicht mehr genau. Da weiß ich noch, da gab es einen Kommentator, der war englischsprachig, der hat eigentlich fast alle Bundesligaspiele gemacht, zumindest fast alle Bayernspieler und das sind ja die einzigen Interessanten. Da sind wir uns ja alle hier im Raum einig und jeder, der dagegen ist, schweigt jetzt. Interessant. Eine große Mehrheit ist dafür. Und der hatte diese wunderbare Gabe, dass er sich über viele kleine Dinge im Spiel ehrlich gefreut hat. Also da kamen immer wieder so Dinge wie What a lovely touch. Und er meinte das aber ehrlich. Das fand ich schön.
Ich auch. Also ich versuche das auch, dass ich mich nach wie vor – also manchmal hört man das auch, dass ich sage, Mensch, einfach hübsch oder – versuche dann meistens ein etwas schöneres Wort zu finden. Ja, finde ich auch. Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass das nicht getan wird. Du hast im Englischen manchmal etwas mehr Präzision in Attributen, wie Lovely. Versuch das mal ins Deutsche zu übersetzen, du wirst scheitern. Und da gibt es die Werte.
Dieser Ball von Thiago, ich finde, das hört sich wie aus einem Gusbar.
Wäre mir zu unpräzise. Aber das ist der Unterschied tatsächlich in der Sprache und nicht nur in der Sprache, wie wir sie lernen, sondern wie wir sie wahrnehmen.
Was macht dir mehr Spaß, Ralph, wenn man so 90 Minuten ganz routiniert durchzieht und nebenher noch ein bisschen Twitter-Replies beantworten kann und seine zwei Liter Schokomilch trinkt oder Multivitaminsacht? Oder wenn es vollkommt, drunter und drüber geht und man vielleicht auch mal diese ganzen Regeln, von denen wir vorhin gesprochen haben, auch mal durchbricht?
Es hat irgendwie beides seinen Charme. Da kann ich jetzt wirklich nicht irgendwie eine Seite präferieren. Das ist beides interessantes, hat beides seine spannenden Facetten. Insofern macht es das, glaube ich, auch aus, dass du natürlich vorher nie weißt, was erwartet dich. Ich habe eben über das Spiel Bolivien-Argentinien gesprochen, wo wir im Vorlauf dachten, oh, heute knallt es richtig. Und diese – ne, Entschuldigung, Uruguay-Argentinien. Ah, Uruguay-Argentinien. Und du denkst so von der Ansetzung, ja, hier knallt es und hier passiert was. Und das waren langweiliges 1-0-Gekicke. Und dann hast du Spiele, von denen du nicht viel erwartest. Und dann schlägt WestBomb Arsenal 3-1. Und das ist ein sensationell geiles Spiel gewesen.
Es unterscheidet sich nicht so sehr von dem, wie es als Zuschauer auch ist. Wenig überraschend. Wir haben noch ein paar sportliche Fragen bekommen. Zum einen sicher von einem HSV-Fan. Wer steigt ab?
Jetzt kann er mal alle Ligen durchgehen, die er so kommentiert.
Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga, gehe ich aus, oder?
Davon gehe ich aus, ja. Oder sind auch Sechziger hier.
Oh, das ist echt schwierig. Das ist echt schwierig.
Also da ist jetzt der Eintracht Frankfurt Podcast.
Die Frankfurter müssen nicht unbedingt Angst haben, irgendwie in den Abstiegsstudel rein zu geraten, denke ich.
Populist, was?
Nö, es wird wie immer eine Mannschaft treffen, die quasi nicht damit rechnet, unten rein zu rutschen. Sascha, es tut mir leid, aber für mich ist der HSV auch wieder unter den letzten Sechs. Ja, aber das ist… sind wir mal ehrlich, es geht eigentlich genauso weiter, wie es die letzten Monate und Jahre insofern erwarte ich da nicht viel mehr. Aber ich glaube, so diese abgeschlagenen Teams, wie du sie jetzt mit Darmstadt und lange Zeit auch mit Engolstadt hattest, dieses Jahr ist Stuttgart für mich zu stabil. Augsburg musst du halt mit auf dem Sturm haben. Du weißt, dass ich in Mainz gespielt habe. Also, keine Ahnung, ich kann dir jetzt fünf, sechs nennen, die da unten ein bisschen rumtun werden, aber die klaren Absteiger. Ich glaube, es wird spannender werden als die letzten Jahre.
Was du ja eigentlich sagen willst, ist, die einzige Art und Weise, diesen spannenden Abstiegskampf zu genießen, ist es jede Schlusskonferenz, von Minute Null bis Minute 180 zu hören.
Extrem wichtig, denn besser kriegt man es nicht aufgearbeitet. Und vorher sollte man sich auf die Zone die Zusammenfassung anschauen.
Der Tisch hier vorne kriegt später noch eine Runde. Möchtest du dich zu den Absteigern äußern?
Ja, im Sinne des Berufes des Kommentators muss ich mich immer und fortwährend unbeliebt machen. Freiburg ist, glaube ich, ein guter Tipp. Ich weiß, die haben eine gute Truppe, keine Frage. Die haben einen guten Trainer, ein stabiles Umfeld. Aber die haben jetzt europäische Dienste.
Ich bin noch nicht so von Mainz überzeugt.
Das könnte eine der beiden Überraschungen werden. Und dann fürchte ich auch, er ist weit genug weg, dass der HSV auch wieder eng wird. Und dann halt ein Team, das wir alle nicht im Ansatz auf dem Schirm haben. Aber das sind so die zwei, drei, die mir jetzt als Erstes in den Sinn schießen. Also bei Mainz habe ich irgendwie dieses Jahr ein schlechtes Gefühl. Ich weiß nicht wieso.
Schauen wir mal. Wir werden es ja erleben, unter anderem ja im Rasenfunk und auf der Sorn mit den Zusammenfassungen, du hast es schon erwähnt. Wenn wir jetzt hier über die Bundesliga sprechen, hätte ich dir dieselbe Frage zur Premier League gestellt. Wärst du dir dann wohler zumute gewesen bei der Antwort? Du bist schon in der Premier League ziemlich tief drin.
Ja, und das ist glaube ich auch das Problem, dass ich jeden Stein in eine Floskel zehnmal umdrehe. Also Huddersfield wird es schwer haben. Ich glaube, die bauen gerade ein bisschen zu viel um von dem, was sie sich gerade erarbeitet haben. Es ist wahnsinnig schwierig, den Abstand aufzuholen zu den Mannschaften, die da über dir drohen. Crystal Palace ist sehr instabil gewesen in den letzten Jahren, was Trainer etc. betrifft. Die haben jetzt einen guten Trainer, die haben auch wieder gut eingekauft. Das haben die anderen halt auch. Das wird sicherlich sehr, sehr schwierig. Die anderen Aufsteiger, also Newcastle, da habe ich keine Bedenken. Die werden das mit Rafa Benitez sehr, sehr gut bestreiten. Es ist echt sau schwer geworden, weil Sunderland, die waren immer so ein Safe-Pick, die sind weg. Ja, die wird nicht schlechter diese Saison. Also das ist ja erstaunlich. Ich hoffe, das ist eine seltene, nicht wertende Einschätzung, die ich mal verlasse. Also Bournemouth habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass irgendwann haben die Mannschaften gecheckt, was die da machen. Aber es ist schwierig, es ist echt schwierig.
Wenn wir jetzt mal ein kurzes Ranking aufmachen. Premier League, Ligue 1, La Liga, Bundesliga und Serie A. Doch, Ralph, da musst du jetzt durch.
Die ist super, die zweite Liga in England.
Oder warum windest du dich so?
Moment, wie definierst du jetzt Ranking?
Welche findest du im Geisten? Das ist für mich das Ranking. Deine Top 5 europäischen Ligen.
Nehmen wir jetzt den großen Durchschnitt. Nehmen wir die Top 5.
Nehmen wir England.
Nein, aber nehmen wir den Durchschnitt der kompletten Liga. Nehmen wir nur die Top 3 Mannschaften. Wenn du die Top 3 Mannschaften nimmst, musst du fast Spanien nach oben setzen.
Bei welcher Liga freust du dich am meisten darauf, die Spiele mit zu verfolgen?
Also am meisten darauf freuen, die Spiele zu kommentieren, das ist definitiv England. Da freue ich mich immer, wenn ich die großen Spiele halt bekomme. 11. August Auftakt Arsenal gegen Leicester.
Wie groß ist die Versuchung, Arsenal London zu sagen, einfach nur danach Twitter zu checken?
Mittlerweile nicht mehr. Also Arsenal London nicht mehr, Menyoo nicht mehr.
Aber wäre doch lustig.
Nein?
Alles schon gehabt. Und auch zum Teil bei anderen gelernt, die den Fehlern gemacht haben. Dann muss ich das nicht wiederholen. Mir ist jetzt Red Bull Leipzig rausgerutscht. Aber ansonsten nein. Also kurz zur Frage, wenn es darum geht, was ich am liebsten kommentiere. Premier League, Bundesliga, Spanien, Italien, Frankreich.
Ich skippe jetzt die Top-5-Frage an dich, weil mir eine viel wichtigere Frage eingefallen ist. Warum sagt ihr nicht auch Raba Leipzig?
Wer würde euch dafür Maß regeln? In unserem Kontext werden wir eigentlich niemals über Leipzig sprechen. Frühestens 2018 in der Champions League dieses Jahr. Ich muss das jetzt nur einmal sagen, weil ich zwei Vorbereitungs-Spiele von Liverpool kommentiert habe und wir darüber gesprochen haben, dass der Verein es sich erlauben kann, 65 Millionen herzulehnen. Weil die haben ja keinen finanziellen Druck, die unterliegen nicht den Gesetzen des Marktes. Und das haben wir halt erwähnt. Aber ansonsten werden die in den nächsten 12 Monaten Leipzig nicht erwähnen müssen.
Aber du könntest es Raba nennen.
Ich hörte davon.
Weißt du, was das mit Raba Leipzig auf sich hat?
Nein.
Das ist die Art und Weise, wie ich diesen Verein bezeichne. Angefangen eher als Witz, aber inzwischen aus tiefer Überzeugung, weil ich den Marketingaspekt nicht ganz so geil finde und den damit so ein bisschen humoristisch unterbreche.
Ich sag dir aber was, wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf. Also die RB Leipzig Diskussion, die möchte ich auch nicht aufmachen. Raba Leipzig, die möchte ich auch nicht aufmachen, weil sie, glaube ich…
Die haben wir auch schon geführt. Tribünengespräch Nr.
8, 5, 5 Stunden. Es gibt auch gute Literatur dazu. Aber ich versuche, wenn ich keine Vorgabe vom Sender bekomme, auch die stadiengebrandeten Namen nicht zu nennen. Wenn ich wirklich mal dazu komme, dass ich Mannschaften aus Ligen kommentiere, die Werksmannschaften sind oder die einfach einen Sponsor im Namen haben dürfen, auch dann nenne ich den nicht. Ich bin nicht dazu gezwungen, weil der Sender mich dafür bezahlt, dass ich Werbung machen muss. Und selbst dann habe ich mich schon unbeliebt gemacht, indem ich das nicht tue, weil ich das nicht einsehe. Schlicht und ergreifend. Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, wie die Stadien in Nürnberg und Co. heißen. Wir haben neulich mal diskutiert, Augsburger Stadion. Ich weiß es nicht und es ist mir auch völlig egal. Das ist nicht meine Aufgabe. Ich bin Journalist und ich mache das nicht.
Und wie oft kommt es vor, dass du gezwungen wirst vom Sender oder dass es da mal so ne indirekte oder direkte Ansage gibt?
Gott sei Dank sehr selten. Weil die Sender im Grunde – das ist so ein journalistischer Krodex, wenn du so willst, um es mal ganz hoch zu hängen, dass wir das nicht tun. Weil einfach Werbung und Inhalt voneinander klar getrennt werden müssen. Das ist das eigentliche Verbrechen an der Pressefreiheit in Deutschland.
Genau. Aber trotzdem gibt es ja sehr viele Kollegen, die gerade auch Red Bull Leipzig sagen und denen ist ganz offensichtlich auch total egal.
Ich habe ein Beispiel, ich nenne jetzt keinen Namen oder Sender oder Medium. Da habe ich die Frage an den LDS, also das ist dann der Leiter der Sendung, habe gesagt, wie verfahren wir hinsichtlich dessen? Und dann sagt der, ja wieso, und dann haben wir so ein bisschen diskutiert und dann kommt der andere Kollege ums Eck und sagt, ja wieso, die haben denn doch dafür bezahlt, wieso sagen wir das nicht?
Haben die dich bezahlt?
Und selbst wenn, also ich bin nicht bezahlbar diesbezüglich. Das macht man nicht. Und der simple Grund ist, das ist Werbung und Werbung, das wollen die, indem sie das bezahlen, aber Werbung hat damit oder hat darin nichts verloren. Schwierig wird es dann, und da sind wir wieder bei der Zuschauerverträglichkeit, wenn ein Stadion wie das Emirates nicht mehr anders zu betiteln ist. Dann wird es schwierig. Bei Manchester im Etihad, Manchester City, versuche ich noch immer ab und zu aufs KOMS auszuweichen, das glaube ich versteht man noch, aber du machst natürlich Felder auf, du führst Leute hinter die Fichte, die dann vielleicht irgendwie googeln müssen oder irgendwie anders. Das ist dann auch nicht gut. Da muss man dann eben auch sagen im Sinne des Zuschauers.
Vorschlag zur Güte, ich würde sagen, immer da, wo der Sponsorname zu präsent ist, immer die Bezeichnung nehmen, die es bei Pro Evolution Soccer gibt.
Nee, Anhalt, Anhalt. Passend zu Fritz von Ton und Taxis irgendwie in meinem Kopf. Bayern München hieß damals Anhalt.
So, wir haben noch zwei sportliche Fragen. Wobei, bei der zweiten bin ich mir nicht sicher, wie viel Sport damit gemeint ist, denn die Eintracht Frankfurt kommt vor. Deswegen fangen wir mit der ersten an. Wir haben jetzt schon über so ein bisschen negative Überraschungen gesprochen. Hast du jemanden auf der Liste, wo du sagst, das könnte die positive Überraschung in der nächsten Bundesligasaison werden? Hier wird lautstraft Eintracht Braunschweig gefordert.
Ja, mir gefällt der Weg, den die Frankfurter in den letzten zwei Jahren mit Kobra gegangen sind. Das ist ein bisschen wie beim Doppelpass. Ich hätte es auch gesagt, wenn ich da hinten sitzen würde. Weil da für mich mal wieder zur Kenntnis, dass jemand installiert wird, der eine Idee hat, der eine Vorstellung hat, dem Macht gegeben wird. Also im gewissen Rahmen. Und dieser Weg wird verfolgt und zwar konsequent. Auch wenn es nicht immer der allerschönste Fußball ist, aber es ist eine Philosophie dahinter zu erkennen. Ich glaube einfach, dass sich das jetzt so weiterentwickelt. Und wenn sie es schaffen, ein bisschen ihre Abhängigkeit von Alex Meyer, der jetzt auch schon in der letzten Saison das eine oder andere Mal gefehlt hat, sich davon ein bisschen zu lösen und ein paar Alternativen aufs Feld zu bringen, kann es interessant werden. Die Frage ist im Kontext einfach, Frankfurt, was ist da eine Überraschung? Ist Euro League eine Überraschung? Wäre Champions League Quali eine Überraschung? Auf jeden Fall alles, was irgendwie einstellig ist. Und ansonsten eher weniger. Danach kommt relativ wenig.
Basti, komm außen rum, dann darfst du die Frage gleich stellen. Und währenddessen darf Uli mir noch seine positive Überraschung der nächsten monosige Saison nennen.
Gemessen an dem, dass sie nicht viel verbessern müssen im Vergleich zur letzten Saison, glaube ich, Stuttgart könnte funktionieren. Ist Hoffenheim noch eine Überraschung? Wahrscheinlich eher weniger. Für Stuttgart wäre es ja schon fast eine Überraschung, wenn sie irgendwie einstellig enden. Und das ist schon drin, glaube ich. Also noch dazu, die haben ja noch so 10 Millionen übrig. Haben eine ganz gute Idee, wenn sie damit verpflichten könnten. Haben, glaube ich, inzwischen ein einigermaßen stabiles Umfeld, wenn auch der eine oder andere behauptet, egobehaftet. Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Schindelmeiser jetzt schon wieder in der Kritik, aber das will ich jetzt nicht auf meine eigene Vorschau vorausgreifen. Wir haben eine Publikumsfrage bekommen von einer Stimme, die euch allen als Podcast-Hörerinnen und Hörern durchaus bekannt sein sollte. Er ist bei 93 zu hören, ist im Eintritt Frankfurt, Podcast zu hören. Er ist nicht zu übersehen, weder bei Twitter noch in eurem Podcatcher. Der großartige Basti Red.
Ja, ich setze mich wahrscheinlich jetzt in die Nesseln, weil ich die Frage an den falschen Spieler stelle. Die Sache ist die, wir haben oft diskutiert und wir haben oft Pro und Contra bekommen beim Altra-Podcast bei 93, weil ich vertrete die Meinung, dass wenn ich Fußballer wäre, dann würde ich zum Beispiel nicht nach Ingolstadt wechseln und ich würde auch – nein, nein, nein, so war das gar nicht gemein. Hallo, nein, ich will nur fragen – Er hat was an Pauli geschrieben. Ja eben, und das ist ja meine Frage jetzt. Leute, ganz bitte ruhig jetzt. Die Sache ist, ich will nur wissen, weil ich oft die These vertrete, es gibt Leute wie Tobias Escher, die analysieren den Fußball auf sehr rationale Weise. Und ich bin jemand, der den Fußball eher auf emotionale Weise analysiert. Mich würde es interessieren, ob es für den Spieler wirklich, und bitte nehmen nicht alle meine Illusionen, eine Rolle spielt, ob du vor 5000 oder vor 50 Außerszenen spielst.
Grundsätzlich eine sehr, sehr legitime Frage. Jetzt kommt es aber, und versteht mich bitte nicht falsch. Für mich ist Fußball was anderes als für dich. Du bist der Fan einer Mannschaft. Du hast eine enge Verbindung, du hast eine emotionale Verbindung zu einem Verein. Die hatte ich auch in meiner Jugend. Ich bin auch in Mannschaften hinterher gefahren, stand in der Kurve, stand am Bus, wollte Autogramme. Das ganze Spiel, was ihr wahrscheinlich in eurer Kindheit und Jugend auch hattet, jetzt ein bisschen vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so Fanboy-mäßig, aber die emotionale Bindung ist da. Mit 17 kam bei mir aber der Turn zum Profi. Und dann musst du das alles beiseite schieben, weil dann wird es der Beruf. Und das ist was völlig anderes. Und du kannst mir glauben, ich hatte eine schöne Zeit in Ingolstadt, wenn ich es mir hätte aussuchen können, wäre ich ja aber noch fünf Jahre beim FC St. Pauli geblieben. Aber zu solchen Wechseln gehören immer zwei Leute oder zwei Parteien. Weil wenn der Verein zu dir kommt und sagt, war schön, aber jetzt brauchen wir dich nicht mehr, dann guckst du, was du machen kannst. So, und ich stand zu dem Zeitpunkt, die Situation war folgende. Mein Vertrag lief noch sechs Monate, ich bin im Winter gewechselt, mein Vertrag lief noch sechs Monate, und man hat mir relativ unmissverständlich klargemacht, dass meine Zeit nach acht Jahren vorbei ist. Man hat zwei neue Innenverteidiger geholt, wir waren sowieso schon fünf, ich habe kaum von Anfang an gespielt, und dann stehst du da, willst noch Fußball spielen, darfst aber nicht mehr. Und hast nicht mehr viele Möglichkeiten, natürlich. Mein erstes Auswärtsspiel mit dem FC Ingolstadt war bei FSV Frankfurt mit 2300 Zuschauern, Freitagsabends. Wenn du jetzt mit dem FC St. Pauli irgendwo hinkommst, dann ist auch die – wie heißt die Arena mittlerweile – Volksbank? Genau. Das Ding ist halt voll. Dann bin ich nach Ingolstadt gewechselt. Ich weiß natürlich, dass das ein Kulturschock war. Trotzdem war das für mich dann wieder eine neue Aufgabe, eine sehr interessante Aufgabe. Und wenn jetzt einer kommt, ja, Werksverein und Zahlen, blablabla. Ich habe weniger verdient als mit dem FC St. Pauli. Und natürlich spiele ich lieber vor 25.000, 30.000. Aber ich kann es mir nicht aussuchen. Nein, ganz kurz.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das Problem war, dass du eben neben mir saßt und ich Ingolstadt benutzt habe. Es ging gar nicht darum. Ich wollte einfach nur wissen. Weil die Sache ist die, jeder, der mich kennt und mich bei 93 hört, weiß ganz genau, ich würde noch viel schneller nach Ingolstadt wechseln, als du, wenn du mir mehr Geld zahlen würdest. Nein, aber das sollte keine Kritik sein, sondern ich wollte nur wissen, ob, wenn ich auswärts stehe, in Gladbach zum Beispiel, die Eintracht zieht in Gladbach, die Eintracht zieht in Gladbach in das CPEB-Kallfinerlein, da stehen 6.000, 7.000 Leute und wir feiern das. Und Herr Gotthard läuft nach dem entscheidenden Elfmeter auf uns zu. Ich wollte nur wissen, ob die Spieler in dem Moment, ab denen das wirklich was bedeutet, oder ob einem das überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Ja, das interessiert uns definitiv, nur du musst das dann ein bisschen den Törn kriegen von der sehr emotionalen Sicht, die du als Fan natürlich hast, zu der professionellen Sicht und zur professionellen Verbindung zu dem Job, den wir haben. Es wird immer gesprochen über Gérard, über Totti, über Maldini und die Jungs, die 12, 14, 15, 18 Jahre in einem Verein gespielt haben. Warum? Wohin soll denn Gérard wechseln? Wohin sollen Totti wechseln? Die spielen bei Top-Vereinen. Die haben alles. Ich kenne so viele Leute, und dazu gehöre ich auch, die irgendwann mal irgendwo wegmusten, nicht weil sie wollten, sondern sie mussten. Bestes Beispiel, aktuell. Was haben alle über David Selke gestimpft? Wie kann der nach Leipzig gehen? Söldner und und und. Wisst ihr, was dahinter steckt? Dahinter steckt Werder Bremen, weil die sagten, du musst gehen, wir brauchen acht Millionen. Und das durfte aber nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gelangen. Ganz kurz, Davy wollte in Bremen bleiben. Es geht darum, dass du auf der Spieler-Ebene eine ganz andere Beziehung zu diesem ganzen Geschäft hast, weil es gezwungenermaßen der Fall ist. Und natürlich spielen wir lieber vor einem 20.000-Auswärts-Block. Aber das können wir uns nicht immer aussuchen.
Aber das meint ihr dann?
Jeder spielt doch. Ich habe es auch nicht als Kritik empfunden. Ich wollte es dir tatsächlich nur aufzeigen, dass auf Spielerseite sehr viel mehr dazukommt, als nur die Stimme. Ich hätte nach meiner Zeit in Mainz nicht mehr bei Eintracht unterschrieben. Das ist zum Beispiel auch so eine Geschichte. Das weiß ich zum Beispiel auch von vielen Spielern, die gewisse Prinzipien haben. Die sagen, ich habe mal bei einem Verein gespielt, und weil ich bei diesem Verein gespielt habe, fallen automatisch zwei, drei Vereine aus dem Raster.
Viel mehr darüber werdet ihr erfahren. Am Mittwoch bist du im Millerntum-Podcast zu Gast.
Richtig, da sprechen wir auch darüber.
Und es könnte sein, dass es sogar bald noch ein Tribünengespräch in ruhigerer Atmosphäre gibt. Vielleicht lade ich aber alle auch wieder ein.
Ja, genau. Kommt alle dazu.
Und dann können wir alle das nochmal genauer besprechen. Uli, Ralph, ich möchte euch sehr herzlich danken. Ihr wart ganz herausragende Gäste unter äußerst schwierigen Bedingungen. Ich danke sehr dem Kommentator bei DAZN. Bei Twitter heißt er etUliHebel, folgt ihm. Uli Hebel. Und außerdem herzlichen Dank. Wir konnten jetzt nicht über Auto sprechen. Mein eigentliches Lieblingsthema, das tut mir sehr leid. Das holen wir dann nach im Felgenfunk. Vielen Dank. Es gibt jetzt die Los Rallos-Woches. Was damit gemeint ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, werdet ihr in einer Woche erfahren haben. Vielen Dank an Ralph Gunesch et Felgenrelle. Danke dir. Und damit danke ich auch euch sehr für die Aufmerksamkeit. Hört den Rasenfunk und alle anderen Podcasts, die es gibt. Rasenfunk.de slash-Portrol ist die wichtigste Internetadresse, denn da gibt es all die hervorragenden Fußball-Podcasts, die Deutschland so zu bieten hat und auch Teile der restlichen Welt. Aber wir sind hier in Bayern ehrlich gesagt zäh da. Ich danke euch fürs Zuhören. Herzlichen.
Das war das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.